do you ever stop eating
i'm hungry are any of your favorite
harry potter lines the same as the casts
from iconic catchphrases and hilarious
quotes to emotional moments
the harry potter cast will never forget
some of their best lines from the series
whether it's their characters
or in others can you guess which lines
are the most beloved by these harry
potter stars
i think so i know so emma watson's
favorite line from the movies
is a hermione classic i'm going to bed
before either of you come up with
another clever idea to get us killed
or worse expelled it gave the 11 year
old actress immense joy to be able to
say such an iconic quote that perfectly
summed up her character
and uh just seemed like the wittiest
cleverest
line rupert grint's favorite line was
more like a catchphrase
and you can probably guess which one it
was i said bloody a lot no i always got
a thrill from saying bloody because it
was kind of like a rude word
director david yates also revealed one
of his favorite wrong lines
you shouted you're chasing draco that's
my girlfriend you numpties
while it's hard for him to pick one
favorite line daniel radcliffe really
enjoyed certain scenes in the order of
the phoenix
especially being with gary oldman and
exploring harry's relationship with
sirius that was my favorite
one probably to film as well tom felton
thoroughly enjoyed playing a bratty
daddy's boy
he's being carried away after being
attacked by uh buckbeak
my father will hear about this though
draco does whine as he's being carried
away that line was actually cut from
this scene
but tom had plenty of other
opportunities to say that exact line
throughout the series
and it's one he's asked to repeat most
often as well as the name of draco's
nemesis
i get asked to say uh potter a lot
potter
potter potter potter evanna lynch has
more than one favorite line one of them
is an iconic luna line
i like you're just as sane as i am
because i
just it just gives no comfort at all to
whoever she says it too
her second favorite line isn't spoken by
her but it's one of dumbledore's most
powerful quotes
of course it's happening in your head
but why does that mean it's not real
she thinks it's one of the most
motivational quotes for artists
and imagine them and if you believe in
them hard enough you can make a movie or
a book or something
bonnie wright's favorite jenny line was
actually an improvised one from her very
first
scene in the harry potter universe good
luck to harry
that was um the beginning and i ended on
the same
set the end of the journey we never
realized this was such a full circle
moment but bonnie's harry potter journey
ending right where it began
just makes the experience even more
magical
matthew lewis's favorite line is one
that perfectly captures neville
longbottom's streak of bad luck
when he's hanging from the chandelier
and he says why is it always me
the line sums up the awkwardness of his
character in the early films
before he develops a skill for heroics
alan rickman had trouble picking a
single line
but filming the last movie was what hit
the hardest especially when the audience
finally gets to see the real severus
snape the last
film it was very cathartic because you
were finally
able to see who he was always
another of his favorite moments was
finally putting away the wands and
getting real with other characters
especially that final scene with
voldemort rafe and i had a scene where
you just thought well
finally there's just a couple of actors
talking to each other
the phelps twins have a few favorite
lines in the movies and just like their
characters they all have to do with the
weasley twins spectacular sense of humor
james's first favorite line let him live
out his childhood dream of talking back
to his mother
i'll be uh honestly women you call
yourself our mother his second favorite
line has to do with the twins love of
sneaking around
and my second one would be mischief
managed which i think sums up the
characters pretty well
oliver's favorite line has to do with
being an annoying older brother
uh mine's just morning the best
way to stop two people getting together
i think i've ever heard david thulis
makes
the perfect remus lupin and he likes to
poke fun
at one of the words he said the most
often in his first harry potter film
which is ridiculous
and uh my other favorite line is bogat
if that's the case then he must have
really enjoyed all his dementor
defeating lessons with harry
ridiculous rave finds his favorite line
as voldemort is one of the series most
dramatic moments and the point where
things got a lot darker in the harry
potter universe
i can touch you now that's my favorite
life
is this one of your favorite voldemort
lines too julie walters favorite line as
molly weasley is so good it often gets a
round of applause
my favorite one has got to be not my
daughter you
the scene is definitely mrs weasley's
most mama bear moment in the entire
series
michael gambin has tons of wonderful
lines to choose from
as albus dumbledore but his favorite is
simple and straight to the point is when
i
i appear as a ghost on this station
platform
and i say harry the emotion in this
scene does most of the talking and i
felt like crying
knowing michael almost cried makes it
even more bittersweet
you're a wizard harry while robbie
coltrane has trouble remembering some of
hagrid's lines from the very first film
his favorite comes from a scene in
diagon alley where he explains why the
young wizard is so famous
you're harry potter you're the one who
got away from
you know who in the movie it's slightly
different
that's why you're famous that's why
everybody knows your name
you're the boy who lived natalia tenna
had
a lot of fun with nymphadora tonks and
her favorite line
is a perfect introduction to the
character's fiery ways
i like it when she says uh don't call me
then fedora gets really angry at madame
moody
she also loves that tongs's hair changes
color in that scene giving us a taste of
what the powerful witch is truly capable
of
helen mccrory's favorite line was one
that gave narcissa malfoy a true moment
of redemption the moment
that she stands up in the forbidden
forest
and says dead it's a great moment for
her character and one of her very last
lines in the entire series
warwick davis played both grip hook and
professor flitwick but his favorite line
comes straight from the hogwarts
professor
and it's a spell we've always wished we
could learn way back in number one
uh as professor flitwick quinn guardian
leviosa
i think for me would be would be the one
it's a line fans ask him to repeat all
the time
it's leviosa not leviosa
he also had a second favorite line that
was one of the dark lords and he can't
help but love it because it was just
such a momentous line in the series
voldemort proclaims harry potter is dead
jason isaac's favorite line comes from
one of his scenes
but his most memorable moment is not
what lucius malfoy said but one of
harry's comebacks
i turned around unexpectedly to him and
i said let us hope mr potter will always
be around to save the day
and he said don't worry i will be both
of these lines were completely
improvised so it's easy to see why an
experienced actor like jason
was so impressed with a young daniel
radcliffe he stayed that impressive ever
since
donal gleason didn't have many lines as
bill weasley but his favorite is one
that delivered tragic news
i'd say mad eyes did and that was my dad
that was just fun
nick moran played scabier one of the
sinister snatchers that captures harry
ron and hermione playing such a creepy
character was fun
and his favorite line definitely sends
chills down our spines
hello beautiful that was it that's the
line that i signed i did
when i get all grass i create quite a
lot of people out with that
helena bonham carter hasn't revealed her
favorite line as bellatrix lestrange but
she loved improvising i keep on trying
to give herself more lines
she even warned her co-stars to be
prepared for some embellishment
just let me improvise